c'était un petit peu la confrontation de
zemmour le visionnaire face à pécresse
la gestionnaire est ce qu'elle va oser
attaquer est ce que zemmour est capable
dans un débat peut-être d'arrondir les
angles pour moi c'était ça l'enjeu de ce
débat
donc vous serez un président un puissant
madame pécresse c'est madame 20h02 à
20h02 elle appellera à voter pour
emmanuel macron la méthode que
j'utilisais pour analyser ce débat c'est
une méthode rhétorique classique ça
consiste à commencer par identifier les
objectifs la deuxième c'est de se
demander quelles stratégies rhétoriques
sont à leur disposition pour atteindre
ces objectifs est la troisième étape est
bien c'est de regarder le débat en
vérifiant quelles sont les stratégies
qu'ils ont effectivement utilisé ce qui
est très intéressant avec eric zemmour
c'est que il il surprend il surprend par
sa capacité à être au niveau quand il
est dans un débat avec des avec des
professionnels de la politique et ça
c'était pas du tout gagné il a très bien
tenu l'échangé face à mélenchon eh bien
il a véritablement changé de dimension
donc ça veut dire que la la candidature
de eric zemmour c'est crédibiliser mais
il faut se rendre compte que ce n'était
pas du tout gagner donc c'est c'est
vraiment un c'est en quelque sorte un
exploit rhétorique pour zemmour d'avoir
réussi à accomplir ça l'enjeu de
pécresse c'était un enjeu de survie je
pense que beaucoup se souviennent du
meeting de meetings commedia dell'arte
où c'était un petit peu après la
catastrophe dans son équipe de campagne
parce qu'elle s'était un peu ridiculisé
et donc la question c'est est-ce qu'elle
peut rebondir après ça quand on
regardait ce qui se disait dans son
équipe de campagne
eh bien c'était quand même que les gens
n'y croyais plus trop c'était un petit
peu le combat de la dernière chance et
on disait que si valérie pécresse arrive
tant bien que mal à résister à pas se
faire complètement écrabouillé ce sera
déjà très bien donc c'était ça l'enjeu
de valérie pécresse c'était de faire jeu
égal avec quelqu'un qui serait dans la
qui serait dans la confrontation pour
moi il ya eu un premier temps du débat
ou zemmour a fait ce qu'il sait bien
faire à savoir il a attaqué la stratégie
qu'il avait c'était de montrer que
valérie pécresse était une girouette un
jour vous êtes pour lutter contre le
grand emplacement le lendemain vous
dites que quand emplacement n'existe pas
vous parler mes mots et puis après vous
ne les assumer
mais oui madame pécresse je suis désolé
de vous dire votre double jeu apparaît
là aux yeux des français madame pécresse
c'est madame 20h02 à 20h02 elle
appellera à voter pour emmanuel macron
car c'est la même c'est le clown
d'emmanuel matin elle vous fera
exactement la même politique mais ce qui
est intéressant c'est que pécresse assez
rapidement offert du répondant de toutes
les façons immigration zéro personne ne
l'a fait personne ne la fera jamais donc
vous serez un président un puissant
quand on est sous influence de poutine
on veut pas se dire patriotes et c'est
pour cela monsieur zemmour que vous êtes
décrédibilisés pour présider la france
moi je voudrais savoir quel est le eric
zemmour que j'ai en face de moi son
idéologie l'a conduit à se tromper
surtout migration j'en parlerai monsieur
zemmour dit n'importe quoi avancer avec
eric zemmour tuttofood su si bien qu'on
a eu un effet que j'avais pas vu depuis
le débat du second tour entre emmanuel
macron et marine le pen à savoir un
débat qui partait absolument dans tous
les sens les journalistes n'arrivais pas
à tenir le temps pourquoi et bien parce
que pécresse a systématiquement contrés
réfuté opposé une résistance à zemmour
sur des terrains sur laquelle j'avoue
que je ne l'attendais pas dans tous les
petits villages demeurent à proximité de
l'arrivée vous entendre dire des chemins
temps les mâles
s'il vous plaît ne m'interrompez pas
s'il vous plaît j'ai le droit aussi de
m'exprimer je vous en prie les femmes
ont leur exprimant là je l'attendais
celle-là a vu la terre dit pourquoi
pourquoi l'attendiez vous parce que vous
êtes tellement vous l'attendiez parce
que vous avez dit elle
mais finalement vous avez dit
madame des classes elmander suivent
également aussi arriver là elle a osé
sortir cette cette carte-là et ça je
m'attendais pas à ce qu'elle a jusque là
et elle a également sorti des sorties
des petits coups sous la ceinture duty
public tâcher
de faire votre entourage me direz vous
entourage c'est quoi votre amitié avec
tariq ramadan où j'ai aucune amitié que
tarik sommes assis on a vu les sms qui
ont été publiés madame frères musulmans
la fidh à sion
elle avait vraiment une stratégie qui
visait à attaquer zemmour et à le
déstabiliser et je trouve que dans une
certaine mesure ça a marché parce que
j'ai vu eric zemmour avoir des
comportements que je n'avais pas vu
depuis un certain temps à beaucoup de
reprises il persifle est il se moquait
son adversaire il faisait des y faisait
des grands gestes donc ça veut dire que
la stratégie de déstabilisation de
valérie pécresse a fonctionné toutes les
fois que zemmour jouer sur le terrain de
la polémique valérie pécresse rentrait
dedans elle rentrait du tac au tac si
bien que elle elle n'a pas joué ici
stratégie de développer ses idées elle a
choisi ses stratégies de toujours
confronté il ya certains moments on
avait vraiment l'impression que c'était
elle qui parasitaient le débat est donc
ça c'est étonnant j'imagine que c'était
la stratégie qu'elle avait que c'est une
stratégie délibérée parce que elle avait
des fiches elle avait des fiches sur des
choses qu'elles pouvaient sortir à un
moment donné pour pouvoir déstabiliser
zemmour pouvoir lagacé s'est pécresse
qui est passé d'une 'bad une
gestionnaire sage à une candidate
pugnace et donc en ce sens la stratégie
qui s'est déroulée c'est plus celle de
pécresse que celle de zemmour pour moi
la tacc la plus forte de d'eric zemmour
c'est quand il a utilisé ses
connaissances historiques pour traiter
valérie pécresse de gaullistes de
pacotille l'esprit gaulliste c'est
défendre la liberté la démocratie la
tradition gaulliste c'est justement le
rapprochement avec la russie madame
pécresse la gaulliste qui cite jean
monnet son ennemi juré encore une fois
vous n'êtes une gaulliste de pacotille
c'est ça une des forces d'eric zemmour
c'est que il a vu qui s'est beaucoup
intéressé à l'histoire il a cette
capacité à m c'est ses interlocuteurs en
contradiction pas face face à la vérité
historique
je dirais qu'il n'y a pas de gagnant
clair dans le sens où quand un débat est
à devient tel un tel brouhaha bas c'est
assez mauvais pour l'image des deux
candidats par contre quand on regarde
les objectifs qui étaient annoncés au
départ avant ce débat et bien du côté
d'eric zemmour y avait quand même cette
idée on va laminer tellement qu'elle va
faire 8% alors que du côté et creysse
c'était beaucoup plus prudent c'était si
on arrive à offrir un peu de répondant
ce sera déjà une victoire donc en ce
sens il n'y a pas de gagnant net par
contre je dirais que pécresse a été plus
capable d'atteindre ces objectifs qui
règle zemmour